[Music]  nintendo switch event is just on the  horizon and we're getting our first look  at some of the platform's third party  accessories through leaks i'm at and  this gamespot news update could use a  little plumbing a bunch of images of  Horry accessories were recently posted  to neogaf and twitter these include your  typical screen protectors game cases and  car chargers but they also reveal a dock  for charging two sets of joy con  controllers a wired controller with a  monstrous looking d-pad and perhaps most  surprisingly a fightstick no fighting  games have been revealed for the switch  as of yet but this possibly suggests  that one is on its way as for official  accessories and other information from  Nintendo we can expect to hear more at  the company's switch presentation on  January 12 at 8pm Pacific for everything  we know about the console already head  over to gamespot and for more news from  the world of video games you're already  in the right place  Oh